si deux coup de spray dans le nez
suffisait pour se protéger du cauvel 19
l'idée vient de l'université de tours et
de l'inra à nous y les premiers
résultats sur les souris sont
prometteurs facile à administrer et à
conserver ce nouveau type de vaccin
serait aussi capable de réduire
drastiquement la transmission du virus
les explications avec aurélie renault
bienvenue à la faculté de pharmacie dans
le parc grandmont dans le laboratoire
bio map
une équipe d'une dizaine de chercheurs
de l'inra et travaille d'arrache-pied la
lutte contre le coronavirus se fait ici
sans aiguille
mais grâce à un spray nasal c'est pas du
tout comme les sprays qu'on voit qu'on
utilise pour se nettoyer le nez ou pour
ceux décongestionner le nez c'est
simplement au lieu d'avoir une seringue
avec une aiguille au bout qui va nous
permettre d'inoculer on va avoir un
petit système qui permet de faire juste
hop une pulvérisation qui sera pratiquée
par quelqu'un d'un personnel qualifié
hospitaliers ou médecins on va le faire
juste une fois pour un premier à une
première vaccination une deuxième fois
ensuite pour un rappel c'est pas un
système de ce prêt qu'on va faire
régulièrement le plus de ce vaccin une
conservation simple entre 4 et 20 degrés
et un côté rassurant notamment chez les
jeunes souvent effrayés par les
aiguilles la formulation elle aussi est
différente des autres vaccins donc à la
différence du moderna ou de files earl
qui font des vaccins arn ou dans notre
vaccin va injecter des protéines
recombinantes ont des protéines qu'on
fabrique nous mêmes grâce à des cultures
cellulaires et
on voit purifiée par la suite et ça on
va le formuler dans notre vaccin et
c'est ça qu'on va pouvoir injecter par
la suite les vaccin injecté par voie
intramusculaire protège mais le risque
dit de contagiosité resterait présent le
spray nasal lui serait un vaccin
stérilisant la personne serait non
seulement protéger des formes graves
mais arrêterait le virus dès que celui
ci rentre en contact avec donc les
fosses nasales et donc ferai en sorte
qu'une personne vaccinée infectées ne
n'aurait plus la capacité d'infecter des
personnes qui les côtoient et ce qui
serait plus à même de dire qu'un jour
les masques pour s envoler
voilà selon les chercheurs les résultats
sont encourageants
une phase de test sur les humains
pourraient débuter dans quelques mois